okay so you get to the end of the first
lesson here are the main takeaways first
build a wonderful amazing product that
creates value charge money try to charge
the user who use it most also think
about profitability from the very
beginning have a strategy to identify
the challenges and manage them then stay
agile for new challenges we can promise
you they'll come in waves and will
surprise you at this point you should
have few thoughts about ways to monetize
your product but wait we'll go into
detail on the monetization models
available for different types of
products in the next lesson please join
us when you're ready